Wonder Woman is ready to send shockwaves
through the superhero movie universe
with her solo big-screen debut this
summer we've got director patty Jenkins
here to set the stage for the upcoming
epic what are some of the essential
qualities of Wonder Woman loving kind
thoughtful badass powerful generous you
know I think these are all very
important a durational qualities yeah
really her really okay so what would you
say about the action scenes in Wonder
Woman how are they different than most
people think before really every action
sequence is from probe point of view and
for her story and so there was no point
in the movie that we were ever like
stepped out and were like look at this
extravaganza it was always you know she
witnesses a battle on a beach that rocks
her world and changes for understanding
of what warfare is and then she comes to
man's world and she sees a war that
everybody says is impenetrable and
nothing can be done about it and she
says what am I going to do about it
so that was what was fun and it makes it
very you know it makes it like
everything else I've ever done
because you're just saying like here's
my character here's what they here's the
journey that they're on how do i how do
I want to experience that how do you do
it so I think that there are things
about that that are not what Supergirl
movies are always having to do that
character moe yeah that's a rather sure
100% characters really incredible and
can you speak at all on that
Diana's relationship with her family
specifically holida yeah I think I think
she has a wonderfully unique and exotic
yet completely familiar and normal
relationship of her family which is she
comes from incredible people who she
looks up to but who she doesn't fully
know everything about their lives as we
all do who she has simple ambitions to
change the world in a very clear way and
yet she has these people around to her
understand and are afraid for her for
what that means she's going to have to
take on in the world and so you know I
treated her first act like a very
classic coming away
here is what I want to do in the world
here are the people saying be careful
Diana I'm not sure I want you to do that
and here's the me that says but I have
to I am going to go and do this and your
parents watch you go and hope you hope
you do well survive I love it okay I got
to ask everybody I've got to ask yes can
you speak on the chemistry between Diana
and Steve Trevor I mean magic that's all
I can and it's not just me just you wait
I mean that's all I can say is just you
wait I've never I am seen a couple like
this on screen and a long time they are
it was the reason that they're so
wonderful is because it was real every
day on set Chris and I would stand and
look at counting God look beautiful
we're a wonderful thing and then Chris
would say something Carol and I would
turn and look at Chris would be like
Pontius guy no it was just so great and
you see the two of them together and
they look so beautiful together but
they're both so on another level in so
many ways but like adore each other and
it was I'm so so excited to be a part of
that love story that's it for now but if
you want to see more videos like this
one covering all the latest d c-- news
click that little subscribe button of
eclss see you next time